[Music]  Justin Timberlake blew the house down  during the Super Bowl fifty two Pepsi  halftime show here are her favorite  moments first Jimmy Fallon kicked things  off introducing his close pal  after performing his new single filthy  on an underground stage JT took us  through the stadium and down memory lane  [Applause]  [Music]  there was an insane dance break on the  field and a touching tribute to Prince  alongside of video projections  JT kept the energy up with a shimmery  rendition of mirrors literally and  concluded his performance on a bright  and happy note singing can't stop the  feeling first on the field and leader in  the stands with the fans  [Applause]  [Music]